en selle à point pour savoir où se
trouvent tout le monde n'a ni tu sera
placé ou le comité carnaval foyal au
grand complet quelques heures avant le
grand jour l'élection des mini rennes
rennes et rennes maire de fort de france
ne doit souffrir d'aucun quoique
l'association veut tenir la promesse
d'un parc aimé césaire survolté dimanche
pendant les élections on ne dort pas
et d'autant plus je suis en coulisses
avec denise derrière c'est là où c'est
chaud pour faire entrer les travestis
les gens peu lente qui à tout bout de
champ si tu as dit que si on est fatigué
grâce à la maison tu t'apprêtes à
toujours dimanche avec au doute
non ça c'est une blague présidence fait
part d une blague
mauvaise surprise de dernière minute une
des candidates ne sera finalement pas
sur le podium dimanche
trouver des postulantes au titre de
reine c'est là toute la difficulté des
associations de carnaval tout ce qui a
comme eux comme qu'on me déduite pour le
carnaval c'est cher ça augmente ça ne
baisse pas donc il y en a des candidates
qui veulent venir pour ceux déjà chez
nous quand elles viennent comme ça
helmand absolument rien donc on est
obligé de se changer pour les habiller
les invitations sont envoyées les
partenaires seront présents place à la
répétition
les candidats devront se présenter sur
le podium en travesti et en tenue
traditionnelle savoir évoluer sur scène
est un critère important pour le jury
[Musique]
comme les candidates au titre de mini
rennes rennes maire de fort de france
nicaise andré et taïna sont fin prêts
pour le grand jour dimanche 14h au parc
aimé césaire
[Musique]